bonsoir et bienvenue dans le 7-8 sport
l'émission consacrée à l'actualité
sportive dans le département tout de
suite le sommaire de votre émission
course à pied plus de 300 personnes ont
pris le départ de l'urban trail de
montigny-le-bretonneux ce dimanche la
compétition a été modifié cette année
l'événement combine désormais du bitume
et des sentiers les détails dans cette
édition
football le tirage du 5e tour de la
coupe de france a été effectué les
affiches maurepas affrontera boulogne
billancourt versailles se déplacera sur
le terrain de vincennes et neauphle
recevra drancy coup de projecteur à
suivre dans ce magazine sur les équipes
de maurepas enough avec nos invités
sports de combat le premier vainqueur
d'un combat et même à offrir fight en
france et y vinuales aux combattants
s'appelle haruna soumaré il vient de
plaisir son portrait dans cette édition
et puis enfin l'émission comme tous les
lundis nous ferons un point complet sur
résultats sportifs du week-end dans lé
département et sera notamment question
du clasico om psg il y aura notamment
une interview de zlatan ibrahimovic le
très urbain de montigny le bretonneux
était programmé ce dimanche au départ du
centre sportif pierre de coubertin
cette année le parcours a été modifié il
se dispute à présent sur des sentiers de
terre et sur du bitume
les coureurs devraient également monté
devait également monter des escaliers
williams elle pour les images nouvelles
formules pour le trail de montigny le
bretonneux pour son édition 2015 la
course à pied était totalement modifié à
travers ce désormais huit quartiers de
la commune pour un parcours total de 13
km les coureurs ont pu tester leur
endurance et leur cheville sur un
circuit hybride une combinaison de
routes de chemins d'escalier et de
trottoirs
cette année c'est la nouvelle version
puisque jusqu'à présent faisait une
course de 10 km
sur du bitume là c'est une première donc
il ya bien sûr il ya des habitués qui
reviennent et qui sont un petit peu
surpris mais sinon on espère créer une
nouvelle habitude pour cette nouvelle
édition l'événement a fait le plein ils
étaient 3 128 à prendre le départ de la
course
parmi les participants on pouvait
apercevoir des débutants mais également
des coureurs aguerris pas le podium je
suis quand même un temps si j'arrive à
faire 45 je serai content en fait
j'habite à me dis donc je trouve que
c'est un événement important et j'ai
envie de participer à ce type
d'événement aujourd'hui c'est de me
faire plaisir
voilà après rapport tu peux faire mieux
que ça pour le trail urbain oui c'est la
première fois
en visant vise le premier ex-aequo la
course a finalement été remporté par
l'imminente un nicolas grange le court a
bouclé les 13 km en 45 minutes et 54
secondes g8 continue donc c'est sympa
quand même gagner chez soi c'est
particulier quand même blessure et puis
voilà quoi donc c'est une première
édition en plus donc c'est toujours
sympa de gagner la première édition
vu le succès rencontré cette année le
trail urbain de montigny-le-bretonneux
devrait être reconduit l'année prochaine
le tirage au sort du 5e tour de la coupe
de france a été effectué la semaine
dernière parmi les affiches maurepas
équipe de division excellence recevra
boulogne billancourt et inhofe liquide
edf ça ressort à drancy équipe de cfa et
de claviers vinoy ne sont évidemment pas
favoris de cette rencontre pour nous
parler de ces deux matchs recevant
benjamin blanche fabien perrot de
maurepas et ben bella faure président de
l'oph et jean luc girard entraineur de
l'oph bonsoir à tous et 4 bat on va
commencer tout de suite par apparemment
pas avec vous benjamin alors maurepas
qui a brillamment triomphé de torcy lors
du tour précédent
est ce que vous êtes vous remis un petit
peu de vos émotions on s'y est remis
qu'à moitié parce que le dimanche pierre
leleux en championnat on a peut-être
subi un peu le la surenchère d'énergie
qu'on avait qu'on avait donné face au
match de coupe de france 4e tour par
contre est on est on est en contre sens
encore un peu dans cette euphorie puis
vraiment lanville envie de
rencontrer une petite ses fans à
recevoir à la maison ça fait plutôt
plaisir way grosse motivation à venir
torcy c'était un gros morceau
c'était déjà un gros morceau when tout à
fait là on passe encore un cap au dessus
et puis et puis c'est des matches de
gala où y'a pas de ya pas de pression
particulière à voir si ce n'est celle et
taquiner les embêter plus possible
fabien qu'elle sait quel a été le
discours du coach sur sur pendant cette
semaine et il vous a plutôt rassuré il a
essayé un petit peu je sais pas de
dégonfler un peu vos têtes après cette
victoire ici pour le coach effectivement
de pouvoir mettre dans de bonnes
conditions des joueurs après un match
comme ça et avec le fouet avec laquelle
en tout cas on a joué l'essentiel en
tout cas le mot du coach a été jeux de
pouvoir se concentrer sur le championnat
vu que c'est une compétition n'a pas
encore remporté un seul match cette
année on est monté de deux divisions
depuis deux ans maintenant et c'est vrai
qu'on a été
on était encore pris à revers hier donc
on avait je pense toujours cette coupe
de france en tête mais mais l'idée voilà
c'est 2-2 pour ce petit peu dans
l'euphorie et préparer ce match de
dimanche au mieux benjamin finalement
cette coupe de france un petit peu votre
bouffée d'oxygène
elle fait du bien elle fait du panda
forcément très bien en ce moment
autre fait que trois matchs donc par
contre qu'il faudrait c'est que tout cet
effet bénéfique de la coupe de france on
puisse on puisse le garder et puis et
puis le le ramener sur le championnat
mais mary et ça fait ça fait du bien
coach est-ce que c'est difficile de
reconcentrer justement un groupe on la
trouve après après une victoire aussi
importante a toujours toujours et on l'a
vu nous aussi sur ce week-end nous ont
malheureusement nous avons perdu à
l'extérieur et on avait sûrement encore
la tête au tour précédent est peut-être
déjà la tête à à dimanche donc c'était
difficile de motiver tout le monde on a
une équipe jeune en plus donc elle a
besoin d'être vraiment soutenu dans en
championnat et là on a fait ça nous a
fait défaut ce week-end benjamin
finalement cette coupe de france c'est
du bonus ou c ou c un match on va dire
clairet classique
enfin avec beaucoup vous avez beaucoup
d'ambition sur cette rencontre
non là on est vraiment dans le bonus les
truffes ce qui est très plaisant c'est
que on a on a un public qui nous suit
vraiment de plus en plus depuis deux
matches on sent que ça ça vient en
nombre
donc là on va vraiment c'est un grand
plaisir de pouvoir à domicile recevoir
la cbb avec notre public
et puis et puis on espère qu'on sera en
tout cas on fera tout ce qu'il faut pour
pour les déranger le plus longtemps
possible
fabien vous sentez peut-être de
l'effervescence même même au sein de la
ville je sais pas on vous en parle
peut-être quand vous vous baladez n'en
meurent pas alors on ne m'en parle pas
encore mais peut-être qu'on nous en
parlera encore plus si on arrive à créer
l'exploit dimanche
en tout cas c'est sûr que dimanche
dernier lors du match de coupe de france
on était vraiment soutenus par notre
public est derrière voilà je voulais
passer un petit bonjour à tous le kop de
maurepas et à tous ceux qui sont qui
sont venus nous voir et on espère les
voir a encore encore très nombreux
dimanche prochain pour nous soutenir
dans ce match qui s'annonce qui
s'annonce très compliqué pour nous en
tout cas
et qu'est ce qu'il faudra faire pour
battre cette équipe du coup joué avec
notre coeur
essayez de
de donner le maximum de nous-mêmes comme
on a pu le faire sur les deux précédents
matches de coupe de france sur ce genre
de match on sait que qu'ils jouent bien
souvent à l'envi et donc on a envie de
tout donner pour pour essayer de battre
cette équipe de la cdp benjamin vous
pensez que le résultat va aller jusqu'où
ça va aller jusqu'aux prolongations
peut-être tirs au but vous les voulez
travailler les tirs au but à
l'entraînement là en ce moment cette
semaine peut-être un peu plus maintenant
faut pas se mentir on plus là on a
commandé un gros morceau en face s'ils
ont déjoué à cote et match on serait ne
serait pas bien lotis donc on va on va
déjà essayer de gérer cette sur
motivation de pas se laisser aspirer de
ne pas courir dans tous les sens pour
déjà tactiquement répondre au duel de la
cdb et puis après avec l'envi sur un
match de foot ça peut ça peut ça peut
apporter des surprises parfois fabien
l'objectif c'est vraiment d'aller le
plus loin possible où vous dites là
maintenant actuellement que ça va être à
ça a été un peu compliqué forcément on a
tous ce match en tête
on sait que pour nous comme on disait au
départ c'est que du bonus la coupe de
france on a fait un très beau parcours
cette année donc là j'ai envie de dire
c'est la cerise sur le gâteau dimanche
donc donc toute façon on ne prend pas ce
match à la légère on va jouer comme
n'importe quel autre match et essayer de
de faire en sorte en tout cas de faire
les efforts tous ensemble et de gagner
ce match collectivement mais anaphore ce
parcours de maurepas ça vous fait
plaisir pour le football est vivant tout
à fait parce que je suis un jeu
profondément convaincu qu'un jour ou
l'autre dans le football yvelinois il
faudra trouver des solutions communes
avec des rapprochements entre clubs et
donc maurepas est très proche de nous et
j'espère peut-être avec moi ou avec
d'autres plus tard mais j'espère qu'un
jour on arrivera à monter un club
berlinois qui pourra représenter
département un niveau un peu supérieur
lorsque le fait si vous voulez devraient
chacun dans son coin montre les limites
des clubs et même si nous on est on est
insolent dsr
on a du mal quand même à rester à ce
niveau là et je pense qu'un regroupement
club yvelinois pourrait permettre
d'avoir un club niveau national football
league ma passe par des bons résultats
on est en coupe de france
oui parce que évidemment à partir du
moment où ils remportent des victoires
comme ça c'est le coup d'éclairage qui
fait qu' on sort un petit peu de
l'anonymat
donc bien sûr c'est très important
d'avoir des résultats comme ça qui
rejaillissent sur je dirais le le
football francilien ile-de-france quoi
jean luc gérard bouzat du même avis que
votre président oui après quand on est
coach notre quotidien jeux comme the
chapel ça c'est le championnat donc le
coup de le coup de phare sur le l'équipe
et club c'est très important
après quand on est coach qu'on veut
c'est le quotidien céder tous les
week-ends c'est le championnat et c'est
là qu'on veut avoir le mc de le maximum
de résultats maintenant du coup vous on
va passer à passer avoue à neauphle vous
avez également gros morceau en ce week
end jean luc oui oui c'est un club de
cfa va encore une fois on est on est
passé le tour d'avant face à un gros
calibre aussi de cfa2 de ligue 2
d'ile-de-france la dranse y aussi c'est
autre chose mais c'est vraiment une
équipe ce qui est depuis quelques années
déjà en cf1 qui qui s'arrache et qui qui
va nous poser sûrement beaucoup de
problèmes donc vous avez eu le scalp de
fleury mérogis au tour précédent une cfa
aussi est-ce que vous pensez que vous
pouvez rééditer l'exploit il n'y a pas
il n'y a pas de raison maintenant on
part pas la fleur au fusil on sait très
bien qu'on n'est pas les favoris après
sur un match tout peut arriver peut
marquer tout de suite on peut marquer à
la 92e on peut aller aux prolongations
au penalty en tout cas nous les nous
nous ferons le maximum pour justement
arrivé à à se qualifier
et quel sera votre discours avant le
début du match oh c'est surtout surtout
prendre du plaisir parce que si ces
joueurs qui n'ont pas l'habitude de
jouer ces équipes là prennent pas de
plaisir c'est pas la peine je pense
qu'il ya d'abord avant tout du plaisir
et avec l'engagement et plaisir mais on
peut arriver avoir une nouvelle surprise
pourquoi pas un art for vous allez
mettre de la pression sur vos joueurs où
vous allez leur dire tout simplement
amuser vous on verra ce qui va se passer
aucune
s'ils ont déjà sur nos tours précédents
le seul fait de rencontrer une équipe
comme fleury a mis une pression
naturelle sur les joueurs et j'ai pensé
qu'il n'était pas utile d'en rajouter
je pense que nous avons bien fait
puisque on a senti quelques heures avant
le match une concentration des joueurs
qu'on n'a pas l'habitude de voir en
championnat et j'ai été agréablement
surpris par la prestation de l'équipe
ce jour là contre fleury puisque nous
avons cette équipe nous était supérieur
mais je trouve que ce jour là on a
fourni du jeu que les joueurs ont été
disons très très concentré et donc
inutile mais la pression on a
certainement bénéficié de l'effet de
surprise lorsque nous avons joué contre
fleury mais là après avoir battu fleury
et le tour le show le week-end précédent
après avoir battu un des favoris de la
dsr en l'occurrence saint-brice je pense
que la foudre en ci va venir vraiment
avec une motivation et une préparation
différente de celle de fleury et je
pense que ça c'est un obstacle encore
plus dure à franchir mais mais mais
c'est la coupe de france et tout est
possible justement pensez peut-être que
l'effet de surprise est passé
du coup oui je pense que l'effet de
surprise est passé après jeudi après ses
deux matches là je pense que fleury a eu
peut-être un petit excès de confiance
quand même on les a vus ce s'agiter à un
quart d'heure de la fin sinon ils sont
resté zen pendant tout le match nous au
bout d'eux lorsqu'il restait 20 25
minutes on a commencé à y croire puisque
le temps travaillé pour nous et ce qui
devait arriver arriva donc je pense
qu'il ya eu un petit excès de confiance
de leur part
cette fois-ci nombre en six ans plus de
sadran 6 et des anciens adversaires par
le passé c'est un club qui joue en dsr
il ya sept huit ans dans le même groupe
que nous on était à la lutte d'ailleurs
une de nos plus belles années en dc on
avait failli monter en division
d'honneur
et donc c'est un club qui en plus seul
sur trois qui nous connaît quoi donc
l'effet de surprise c'est fini quoi
benjamin blanchet ce qu'on pensait que
nov peut créer l'exploit
si l'on fait une fois il exactement
exactement ils sont à domicile a aussi
avec
avec leur public pour eux avec leur
terrain sur place et ils l'ont fait une
fois
moi je vois pas pourquoi ils pourraient
être fermées jean luc girard on va
peut-être un petit peu s'intéressent à
votre cas vous êtes à laver il ya
seulement trois semaines
voilà maintenant à neauphle vous venez
justement de du red star vous avez
évolué vous avez fait plus de 280 match
avec le red star dans votre carrière en
lui en deuxième division
est ce que vous apportez peut-être cette
expérience à votre équipe ou ou est-ce
que sur le premier match tout simplement
les joueurs ont répondu présent et votre
expérience n'a pas forcément changé
quelque chose
à l'issue du match n'ont cessé plus
essayé par rapport à des consignes
tactiques mais vraiment minime par
rapport au fait que je connais ses
filles effectivement le niveau même de
ces femmes donc qui a été très bien
respecté par les joueurs
après comme je le disais c'est leur
talent individuel et la motivation
naturelle qu'ils ont pu pour faire cette
rencontre qui a fait qu a fait la
différence
président vous l'avez choisi parce que
c'était une personne d'expérience ou
parce que tout simplement
enfin pensé qu'il pouvait apporter
qu'ils pouvaient apporter un petit plus
à l'équipe
dans un moment peut-être un petit peu
délicat séance en début de saison alors
dg je pense qu'il est un petit peu
modeste parce que on a senti quand même
su province qu'il est là mais on a senti
sa patte quand même dès les premiers
contacts dès l'après première
présentation quand je vais présenter au
groupe avec quelques disons consignes
tactiques et je pense que
ça a quand même importé bon pis aller
fait novateur 50
l'électrochoc et voilà quand il ya un
nouvel entraîneur les joueurs ce qui
était un peu plus installer le sont un
peu moins et ce qu'il l'était pas en
plus d'espoir d'en avoir un petit peu
plus voilà ça c'est fait si vous voulez
un petit peu bizarrement ce changement
d'entraîneur puisque nous avait un
entraîneur depuis une saison et un moi
qui ai dû nous quitter pour des raisons
professionnelles et personnelles que je
n'ai pas vraiment réussi à approfondir
mes boeuf bref c'est le passé et il nous
a il nous a fallu trouver une solution
très très rapidement il a fallu donc
j'active un petit peu les réseaux du
club mais réseau et puis on est tombé
sur le ya pas énormément de candidatures
mais on a eu la chance d'avoir la la
disponibilité de jean luc girard qui est
comme vous l'avez dit un jour un
ex-joueur professionnel mais aussi un
entraîneur puisqu'il est entraîneur du
ray star directeur sportif du ray star
il a entraîné pour nationale il s'est
fait savoir ça vous l'avez choisi parmi
parmi les possibilités qu'on avait et
victime ans son expérience nous a tout
de suite attiré je pense d'ailleurs
c'est ce que j'ai un peu dit aux joueurs
que il va falloir que lui essaye de se
rapprocher un petit peu du niveau de
hockey l'on se trouve
mais j'espère également que les joueurs
vont essayer de grimper un petit peu
pour s'approcher de sa façon de
travailler de ces exigences qui sont un
peu plus professionnel que qu'amateur
cheikh jarrah qui connaissait également
très bien le football illinois vous
habitez d'ailleurs à guyancourt
ce football yvelinoise ça vous tenait à
coeur de le représenter à travers
l'équipe ben oui parce que j'ai c'est
vrai que j'avais encore il ya quelques
mois j'ai entraîné encore ivry en cfa su
retrouver son club ça fait partie du
boulot d'entraîneur comme on dit
j'habite les yvelines j'ai même si j'ai
voyagé au travers de club
j'habite dans les lignes depuis
longtemps donc revenir quand le
président faure m'a appelé j'ai réfléchi
alors un petit peu je peux pas dire que
j'ai fait un peu semblant de réfléchir
j'ai quand même pris lé recul mais ça
n'a pas duré très longtemps et j'ai
effectivement accepté de devenir j'étais
à côté de chez moi les yvelines c'est
quand même important pour moi j'ai
pratiquement habiter tout le temps dans
les yvelines
donc non non c'est important et on va
parler enfin dernier petit mot sur la
coupe de france
quel est votre plus grand rêve en coupe
de france ça serait d'aller le plus loin
possible
quel est votre plus grand rêve se dire
que face à une compétition comme ça on a
la possibilité de jouer avec l'élite
savoir les ligue 1 s'il fallait avoir un
rêve se dire qu'à domicile on reçoit une
ligue 1 on serait en serait ouais ce
serait on serait proche à mon avis oui
mais vous de votre côté à nous je ne
sais pas un résident ni dans ses la
coupe ces compétitions très aléatoires
donc nous je dirais que si on passer ce
tour lance la maman ravie
après tout dépend du tirage vous savez
bien que à partir du 6ème 7ème tour il
ya plus beaucoup de petites équipes
c'est difficile de fixer un objectif un
rêve mais bon bien sûr le plus loin
possible je n'invente rien en disant ça
bon si on atteignait lé 6e 7e tour si on
pouvait jouer contre une équipe
professionnelle ce serait sympathique
quoi mais restons les pieds sur terre
quand même merci à tous les cas elle est
passée sur ce plateau on souhaite bon
courage pour ce 5e tour de la coupe de
france qui a lieu ce dimanche je le
rappelle
coup de projecteur à présent sur le
sport de combat le mma il est rentré
dans l'histoire du sport français haruna
soumaré plaisir wa de 29 ans est devenu
le tout premier vainqueur d'un combat
est même à un sport jusqu'ici interdite
en france il a terrassé le 19 septembre
dernier christophe de cordes au
troisième rang devant plus de 1600
spectateurs au cirque d'hiver de paris
portrait de ce colosse d'1 mètre 84 et
le diwan pour les images
soumaré 29 ans pratique le mma les arts
martiaux mixtes depuis 2003 le samedi 19
septembre ce combattant licencié au sdcl
senteurs de maurepas est rentré dans
l'histoire de cette discipline en
devenant le tout premier vainqueur d'un
combat officiel en france il a dominé
christophe de cordes troisième rang
devant plus de 1600 spectateurs au
cirque d'hiver de paris
une joie intense pour le plaisir
originaire du quartier du mail
c'est l'aboutissement d'un long chemin
parce que j'ai fait une rupture de
quatre ans voilà j'avais arrêté pendant
quatre ans je m'étais consacré un peu à
mon travail et ma vie de famille et du
coup on pense à tout ça on
on pense à tous ceux qui m'ont soutenu
pour tous les amis qui nous ont
conseillé de plus tout jeune en fait les
sports de combat font partie intégrante
de la vie d'haruna soumaré champion de
karaté de taekwondo et de boxe française
dans sa jeunesse
ce colosse d'1 mètre quatre-vingt pour
84 kg de muscles a ensuite suivi son
grand frère mamadou dans le mma un
parcours qui lui a permis de devenir un
combattant complet haruna est un gars
qui a deux coeurs quatre poumons
ses points forts ses voix c'est ça c'est
sa condition physique et son mental
après il a une boxe qui est pas mal il a
un seul qui qui doit s'améliorer il a
une qui est acceptable
il a un vrai coeur il a dit l'avoir une
condition physique hors norme et voilà
et un mental qui correspond à un
combattant mes points forts c'est les
jambes
voilà boxe française taekwondo mais en
faisant du mma je me suis aussi
spécialisée dans la lutte
donc aujourd'hui je me retrouve un peu
plus à l'aise dans la lutte que banques
les bois après cette victoire la
carrière professionnelle d'haruna
devrait décoller le plaisir wa devraient
être sollicités dans les prochains mois
pour participer à des combats européen
en france la pratique du mma en
compétition reste strictement interdite
on passe maintenant résultats sportifs
du week-end dans le département on
continue par du football
hier soir vous étiez des millions de
téléspectateurs devant le clasico paris
saint germain marseille et parisiens qui
représente le département dans le
championnat de france l'ont emporté 2
buts à 1 au parc des princes avec un
doublé du suédois zlatan ibrahimovic sur
penalty avant la mi temps les
marseillais avaient pourtant ouvert la
marque par le jeune belge ritchie
batshuayi en deuxième mi temps l'om a
même raté un penalty pour revenir au
score
on écoute les réactions des deux camps
après la rencontre il était au micro de
william l
on a rencontré une très belle équipe de
marseille qui a été très joueuse qui a
été récompensé de sa prise de risques
puisqu'elle a elle a mené au score 1 0
je pense que techniquement
les marseillais ont été meilleurs que
nous durant les trente premières minutes
donc ça a été oui match difficile très
difficile même si mon équipe n'a jamais
baissé les bras
on essaie de les presser haut on a vu
que c'est tout est plus difficile pour
eux quand ils étaient pressés on en
récupère lé ballon on a eu des occasions
je ne souhaite pas que mon équipe jouer
vois les choses comme une petite équipe
et nous contentons président on est
seuls intérêts aux algues gravats les
enterrements et que nous repartions
d'ici en étant satisfait juste parce que
nous avons nous avons perdu pour le pain
sur l'emballage et stahl contento ce
grave incident le rôle de parti on ne
peut pas non plus se satisfaire être
content du fait que trap a été le
meilleur joueur de cette rencontre ce
soir ce n'était pas facile mais on a
fait beaucoup pour gagner ce match et en
fait on est très content je suis c'est
le plus noir et c'est important pour les
supporters etc
même pour nous art core est également
tombée pendant ce match zlatan
ibrahimovic est devenu le meilleur
buteur du paris saint germain avec 110
buts
il devance le portugais pedro miguel
pauleta le suédois est au micro de
téléphiles à 78 bien sûr que j'ai
ressenti quelque chose de spécial mais
le plus important c'était de gagner le
match 2-1
on passe à la promotion d'honneur trappe
réalise le début de saison parfait et
rapide se sont imposés à l'extérieur
contre malakoff lors de la 3e journée du
championnat
score final 1 but à 0 classement trappe
et premier de sa poule avec trois
victoires en trois matches 11 buts
marqués et seulement 3 encaissés
et devant ce saint leu et oui à la
différence de buts après le football on
passe au rugby verset s'est imposé 27 à
22 61 au stade de porchefontaine contre
metz en fédérale 3 les yvelinois ont
réussi à mettre du rythme dans la
rencontre avec des redoublements de
passes pour l'emporter après trois
journées les versets ils sont sixièmes
du classement de la poule 2 e de leur
championnat avec une victoire un nul et
une défaite au tour sur le début de
saison des yvelinois avec le troisième
ligne vincent rodionoff et l'entraîneur
baptiste gouache
on a commencé un match si rugueux à
epernay où ses traits épais ou leur dire
le bilan économique leur permet d'avoir
des joueurs on va dire un peu plus épais
que la moyenne
du coup c'est une équipe assez
dangereuse donc les déplacements chez
eux était compliquée et ensuite le
deuxième match à boulogne ont fait match
nul
deuxième match de l'année un peu plus
compliquées entrent en place notre jeu
ils nous prennent sur le début sur des
individualités notamment au niveau de
leur numéro 5 début de saison est assez
difficile puisque un eurogroupe des
joueurs qui sont assez jeunes à la barre
avoir notre ossature a constitué par
rapport à cette équipe mais très
intéressant trois sur trois pour le sky
rugby les joueurs coachés par thomas
payan largement dominé triel les mureaux
sur leur terrain pour leur premier match
de la saison à domicile
pascal rugby a fait parler son armada
offensive devant leurs supporters pour
s'imposer dans ce derby sur le score de
26 à 3 une démonstration qui leur permet
de grimper à la 2e place du classement
avec 12 points au tour sur ce match avec
l'entraîneur saint quentinois à thomas
payet on a dominé du début à la fin ce
match donc on mérite vraiment vraiment
la victoire voir on aurait pu avoir le
bonus sur la fin il nous échappe mais
bon on avait six vit la victoire c'est
le principal je pense que notre force
c'est de pouvoir alterner à la fois sur
du jeu avec les avants et du jeu avec
les trois quarts nos adversaires ont
proposé uniquement du jeu ont proposé
uniquement du jeu devant nous on a su
alterner le jeu et je pense qu'ils l'ont
pas tué le rythme soit sur la longueur
méritée on produit du jeu face à un
adversaire qui coire est fini premier de
la poule
il fallait aller gagner à domicile
absolument pas pour gagner trois matches
est passé au dessus dans le placement
quoi l'ambiance était au beau fixe au
sky rugby en passant handball début de
saison surprenant des féminines de
montigny-le-bretonneux promu en national
une cette saison les joueuses de
philippe l'étrange ont enregistré une
deuxième victoire en trois matches
disputés lors de bals aux yvelinois se
sont imposés à domicile contre erdre et
loire sur le score de 27 à 23
au classement montigny se place à la
cinquième place du championnat à deux
points du leader saint grégoire en
cyclisme sur piste ont disputé ce
week-end les championnats de france et
c'est un minimum 1 qui s'est distingué
françois pervis a remporté l'épreuve du
keirin à bordeaux il admis dominé en
finale benjamin et de l'ain et le
plaisir ou à michael d'almeida dans le
vélodrome de bordeaux
il s'agit du quatorzième titre de
champion de france de la carrière de
françois pervis dans la catégorie junior
à noter que françois pervis n'a pas
voulu s'aligner sur l'épreuve du
kilomètre alors qu'il était champion de
france en titre
prochaine compétition pour les ni mon
teint et championnats d'europe et un
évènement organisé du 14 au 18 18
octobre en suisse en referme ce magazine
par du basket début de saison compliqué
pour trappe en nationale 3 après leur
défaite contre marly le roi lors de la
première journée les joueurs de mostafa
el hafidi se sont inclinés de justesse
au buzzer sur leur parquet contre viry
châtillon score final 67 66 pour les
essonniens au classement trappe et à
leur a à l'heure actuelle lanterne rouge
de la poule b de nationale 3 c'est la
fin de ce statut de sport merci d'avoir
suivi je vous retrouve lundi prochain
pour un nouveau magazine très belle
soirée sur tv fil 78